Helge Paulessen.
Wie bitte?
Herr?
Helge Paulessen.
Könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, meine Vornamen sind Helge, P wie Henry, E wie Emil, L wie Ludwig, G wie Gustav, E wie Emil.
Ja.
Meine Vornamen sind Paulessen, P wie Paula, A wie Anton, U wie Ulrich, L wie Ludwig, E wie Emil,
S E wie Emil, N wie Nordroth.
Ist Paulessen zusammen oder getrennt?
Zusammen.
Ok, Frau Paulessen, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, 65 Jahre.
65 Jahre alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
26.11.1961.
61, ok.
Frau Paulessen, wie groß sind Sie?
156, 156.
Ok, wissen Sie wie viel Sie wegen?
Ja, 85 Kilogramm, Herr Doktor.
85 Kilogramm, ok.
Frau Paulessen, was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Seit gestern Abend habe ich Pylosis aufgetreten, aber sehr starke Schmerzen.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie mir zeigen?
Im unteren Bauch.
Im linken Unterbauch.
Frau Paulessen, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeutet.
Ja Herr Doktor, 5, aber bei Stürgang verschieben sich die Schmerzen.
Ok, bei Stürgang verschieben sich die Schmerzen.
Ok, das habe ich notiert.
Brauchen Sie Schmerzmittel oder könnten Sie diese Schmerzen aus bis zum Ende des Schmerzes aushalten?
Nein, kein Problem.
Ok, strallen die Schmerzen in die Drei aus?
Ja Herr Doktor, im mitten Unterbauch strallen meine Schmerzen aus.
Im mittleren Unterbauch, ok, das habe ich notiert.
Sind die Schmerzen, Sie haben gesagt, plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, plötzlich.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder verschwinden Sie zeitweise?
Ja, immer dauerhaft, aber besonders bei Stürgang ist die Schmerzen stärker.
Ok, Frau Paulessen, werden die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit stärker oder nachher?
Herr Doktor, ich habe gesagt, ich habe immer stärke Schmerzen.
Nein, nein, ich meine im Laufe der Zeit.
Immer gleich oder?
Immer gleich.
Gleich, nicht stärker werden, das ist wichtig für uns.
Ok, solche Kleinigkeiten sind für uns wichtig, um eine genaue Diagnose zu stellen.
Sind Sie nervös?
Nein, keine Ahnung, ich bin nicht ganz stressig.
Ok, Frau Paulessen, könnten Sie mir diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ja, meine Schmerzen drücken, Herr Doktor.
Drücken, ok, das habe ich notiert, Frau Paulessen.
Frau Paulessen, gibt es einen Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie sich am Bauch verletzt oder etwas gegessen?
Nein, nein, ich habe nichts mehr.
Ok, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert?
Nein, ich habe nichts mehr, Herr Doktor.
Außer Stuhlgang, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen versteckt?
Wie bitte?
Ja.
Was?
Was ist das?
Ich habe nichts mehr.
Ok, haben Sie Anischebechwerden früher gehabt?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich bin mit 20 Jahren Anischebechwerde hatte.
Und bei mir wurde die Operation durchgeführt,
bin ich dann entfernt durchgeführt.
Mit 20 Jahren Lebensjahr?
Ja.
Das habe ich notiert.
War die Operation komplikationslos?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein oder?
Keine, keine Operation.
Keine Operation, ok, keine Komplikation.
Ok, das habe ich notiert, Frau Paulessen.
Frau Paulessen, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Oder etwas probiert?
Nein, ich habe keine Medikamente eingenommen, aber seit zwei Wochen habe ich Verstopfung, Herr Doktor.
Seit zwei Wochen, ach so.
Ich habe aus dem Aufführmittel gekauft, dann nehme ich zwei oder dreimal Aufführmittel angenommen.
Zweimal, Sie haben...
Zweimal, dreimal.
Hat dieses Aufführen Ihnen dabei geholfen?
Ja, nicht geholfen, aber ja, ein bisschen.
Ein oder zweimal in der Woche habe ich das Aufführen.
Ein oder zweimal?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Entschuldigung, leiden Sie unter Verstopfung?
Nur seit zwei Wochen oder früher leiden Sie häufiger?
Seit zwei Wochen habe ich diese Schmerzen bemerkt.
Aber seit einem Monat habe ich ein bisschen Verstopfung.
Okay, gibt es in Ihrer Stuhl Blut?
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, hellrotes Blut habe ich gesehen.
Das war gemischt oder ausspürt?
Nein, überflaschen.
Überflaschen, rotes Blut haben Sie bemerkt.
Wann haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, gestern, gestern, morgen, Herr Doktor.
Wann war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Gestern Morgen, Herr Doktor.
Gestern Morgen?
Ja.
Okay, das habe ich bemerkt.
Es gab hellrotes Blut darin.
Wechselten Sie bei Ihnen Durchfall und Verstopfung ab?
Oder leiden Sie immer mit Verstopfung?
Manchmal, nach der Verstopfung, habe ich ein bisschen Schütz und Diary gemacht.
Aber alle habe ich verstopft.
Okay, gehen Sie im Winter ab?
Ja, kein Problem.
Gut zu hören.
Haben Sie viel Beisterfluss, Nachschweiß oder kalten Schweiß?
Ja, gestern Abend habe ich gemisst.
Meine Temperatur ist 38,5 Grad Celsius.
Heute Morgen ist es 38,2 Grad Celsius.
38,2 Grad Celsius.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Atemmut oder Herzrasen?
Nein, ich habe keine Überflaschen.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Überflaschen oder Überflaschen haben?
Ja, ich habe Überflaschen, aber keine Überflaschen.
Aber nicht so stark.
Seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Seit 2-3 Tagen.
Seit 3 Tagen.
Okay, aber keine Überflaschen.
Ja, Frau Paulessen, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, ich habe mehrmals auf die Toilette gegangen.
Seit wann?
Seit einer Woche, Herr Doktor.
Seit einer Woche gehen Sie häufiger als früher oder als gewöhnliches zur Toilette?
Ja, außerdem habe ich beim Wasserlassen schon viel genug gehabt.
Haben Sie Urin?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ist Urin Menge?
Weniger als angewöhnliches oder viel mehr als angewöhnliches?
Weniger als angewöhnliches.
Frau Paulessen, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit ist kein Problem, aber seit 2 Tagen habe ich nicht gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Keine Gewichtsveränderung, Herr Wiener See.
Schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Schwierigkeiten einzuschlafen?
Ich habe keine Probleme, aber seit 2 Tagen habe ich gut geschlafen.
Können Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen nicht schlafen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Das habe ich notiert.
Frau Paulessen, Sie sind 65 Jahre alt.
Ich denke, Sie sind in den Wechseljahren meiner Pause.
Seit wann sind Sie in meiner Pause?
Seit 20 Jahren, Herr Doktor.
Seit 20 Jahren.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frau regelmäßig?
Ja, besuchen. Aber ich habe eine Frage, Herr Doktor.
Ist diese Frage wirklich?
Ja, natürlich wichtig.
Frau Paulessen, diese regelmäßige Art Besuchen
können viele ernsthafte Krankheiten früh erkennen.
Ja, um viele Krankheiten früh zu erkennen,
sollten Sie diese regelmäßige Art Besuchen machen.
Das ist wichtig.
Okay.
Mindestens zweimal pro Jahr empfehlen wir.
Gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte, Frau Paulessen?
Zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit.
Herr Doktor, Bluthochdruck habe ich seit 2 Jahren.
Seit 2 Jahren.
Aber ich habe immer kontrollieren.
Gestern Abend war mein Bluthochdruck 120 zu 18 mm.
Okay, das war gut zu hören.
Noch etwas?
Nein.
Und außer dieser Blüntalentfernung hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Okay, Sie nehmen zweimal oder Sie haben zweimal Abführsmittel eingenommen
wegen dieser Verstopfung.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, natürlich Herr Doktor.
Am 5. April nehme ich an.
Am 5. April.
Okay, das habe ich notiert.
Danke für alle Informationen, Frau Paulessen.
Frau Paulessen, sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, ich habe keine Allergien.
Aber Herr Doktor, wenn ich bei meiner Operation durchgeführt würde,
habe ich nach der Operation das Bauchschmerzen geblieben.
Nach der Operation?
Ja.
Okay, vermutlich sind diese Beschwerden wegen der Narkose aufgetreten.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Okay, darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben, Frau Paulessen?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, nein, nein.
Gut zu hören.
Warum haben Sie gut?
Sie rauchen nicht, Sie trinken kein Alkohol.
Das ist sehr gut, solche Erfahrungen zu hören.
Ja, ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Also, routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben?
Nein, nein, nein, Herr Doktor.
Ach so gut, ja, ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, natürlich.
Tragen Sie Sport regelmäßig?
Nein, nein, leider.
Warum haben Sie nicht?
Gut gesagt.
Das ist nicht gut.
Sie sollten auf jeden Fall, egal wie alt Sie sind, regelmäßig Sport machen.
Mindestens zwei oder drei Mal pro Woche ist das sehr wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Frau Paulessen, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, mein Vater ist leider verstorben.
Es tut mir leid für Ihren Verlust.
Woran ist er verstorben?
Bluska hatte eine Krankheit mit 20 Jahren.
Von Komplikationen an Bluska ist er plötzlich verstorben.
Es tut mir leid.
Vielen Dank.
Was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist 80 Jahre alt.
80 Jahre alt?
Ja, natürlich.
Kann das richtig sein?
Es gibt nur 14 Jahre zwischen Ihrer Mutter und Ihnen.
Ja.
Kann das sein?
Ja, klar.
Er leidet an Atatschühe.
Er liegt im Bett, Herr Doktor.
Was ist Atatschühe, Herr Doktor?
Atatschühe ist ein Gesundheitszustand, das wir natürlich in hoheren Altern beobachten.
Viele Beschwerden, Müdigkeit, Betriebslosigkeit oder Schmerzen können die Patienten haben.
Wir nennen dieses Beschwerdebild Altersschwäche.
Wie sagen Sie das in Medizin?
Ist das wichtig?
Schwächer?
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wir können das so nutzen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Ledig und haben Sie Kinder, Frau Paulessen?
Nein.
Ich denke, Sie sind im Ruhestand.
Ja, ich bin im Ruhestand, aber vorher als Sekretärin habe ich gearbeitet.
Ja, Sekretärin.
Was habe ich notiert, Frau Paulessen.
Frau Paulessen, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf Entzündung der Darmen.
Beziehungsweise Entzündung von kleinen Ausstülpungen im Darm.
Das bedeutet, dass sich kleine Ausstülpungen im Darm entzündet haben.
Manchmal können Sie...
Was für eine Ausstülpung?
Ich erkläre.
Nein, das ist kein Krebs.
Wegen langsameren Obstipationen können Menschen meistens manche Ausstülpungen im Darm.
Okay?
Okay.
Und manchmal können sich diese Ausstülpungen entzünden.
Und wir nennen diese Krankheitsbild so.
Okay?
Ausstülpungen bedeuten Ballonartikel für Öl.
Wie bitte?
Wir können es auch so formulieren.
Ja, das ist auch gut.
Okay.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deshalb müssen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Anschließend Ihnen für das Labor Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde auch eine EKG schreiben, um mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Danach werde ich einen Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Okay?
Ja, okay.
Sobald die Ergebnisse, die Befunde vorliegen, beschiebe ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Haben Sie Fragen oder gibt es noch etwas, das Sie uns hören möchten?
Ja Herr Doktor, besteht ein Lebensgefahr oder werde ich sterben?
Nein, das ist ein Problem.
Nein, das ist eine Entzündung.
Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Natürlich ist das etwas zuführend, um es genau zu sagen.
Aber vermutlich können wir diese Erkrankungen oder ihre Beschwerden mit Medikamentös behandeln.
Denken Sie die Operation?
Jetzt ist es früh.
Ich möchte nicht darüber sprechen, aber falls eine Operation ist, bitte haben Sie keine Angst.
Sie sind in besten Händen.
Unsere Kollegen sind sehr erfahren und sehr ausgebildet.
Solche Operationen werden bei uns oft in der Routine.
Deswegen haben Sie viel Erfahrung.
Aber wie gesagt sollten Sie die Medikamentös vermutlich behandeln.
Okay.
Behandelt werden.
Entschuldigung, sollten Sie behandelt werden.
Vielen Dank Herr Doktor.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ja bitte, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Guten Tag.
Frau Stötke.
Natriumwert 172 Millimiter.
Vielen Dank, aber ich brauche eine Wiederholung der Name.
Könnten Sie das wiederholen oder bestabieren?
Stöte, Stöte, Stöte.
Okay, Stöte.
Können Sie uns die Verkaufszeiten der Erdbeere mit der Zeit einbringen?
Ja gerne.
Okay.
Tschüss, auf Wiederhören.
Ketin, können Sie mal schauen?
Okay, ich kann es sehen.
Ich habe keine Zeit, aber ich bin schon da.
Ich habe keine Zeit.
Kemerich hat gesagt, dass ich die Zeit aufsetzen sollte.
Aber er hat es tatsächlich aufsetzt.
Es sind 22 Minuten.
Okay.
Dann sind wir um 19 Uhr fertig.
Ja, dann haben Sie mich sehr oft gefragt.
Aber es war schön.
Ihr seid auch gesund.
Die Patienten fragen schon ein paar Fragen.
Sie sagen, dass sie nicht alle Erfahrungen schon haben.
Guten Tag.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle, muss ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Gerne.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass Frau Stütke einen Natriumwert von 172 Millimol pro Liter hat.
Dieser Wert ist stark erhöht.
Er entspricht einer Hypernatrium.
Weil der Bereich für Natrium zwischen 135 bis 145 Millimol pro Liter liegt.
Deswegen habe ich das so gedacht.
Oder können wir das so nennen.
Warum sagen Sie oder geben Sie diese Bescheid zu mir?
Weil Sie Oberarzt sind und dafür zuständig sind.
Aber dieser Patient ist auf dem vierten Etage.
Ich würde den zuständigen Arzt kontaktieren und ihn über den Wert informieren.
Wie würden Sie diese Patienten, ich meine nicht diese Patienten, diese Natriumwert behandeln?
Könnten Sie kurz erklären?
Natürlich. Die Ursachen sind sehr wichtig.
Aber Hauptsache ist die Symptome.
Wahrscheinlich hat diese Patientin entsprechende Symptome.
Deswegen soll ich sofort behandeln.
Aber nicht schnell.
Ich muss langsam diesen Wert korrektieren.
Ja.
Wegen eines Risikos.
Wegen des Risikos eines Gehirnödem.
Wenn Natrium zu schnell korrigiert wird, kann das sein.
Kann das ein Gehirnödem auftreten.
Deswegen soll ich es so behandeln.
Wie würden Sie behandeln?
Ich würde zuerst hypotonische Kochsalzlösungen oder Glykosalzlösungen verabreichen.
Aber je nach Kontrolle kann ich die Therapie oder die Lösungen anpassen.
Die Hauptsache ist, je nachdem, wie alt die Hypernatrium ist, können wir die Lösungen anpassen.
Zum Beispiel bei hypovolemischen oder isovolemischen Hypernatrium verabreichen wir halb-isotone Kochsalzlösungen.
Aber mit hypertonischen Hypernatrium sollten wir mit Glykosalzlösungen behandeln.
Wie viel stündlich würden Sie den Blut kontrollieren?
Je nach dem Zustand der Patientin oder der Labor, können wir in alle zwei oder vier Stunden die Natriumwerte kontrollieren.
Aber täglich kann man maximal 10 mL reduzieren.
Man kann die Werte reduzieren, korrigieren.
Danke schön.
Können Sie andere Patienten, andere Patientinnen und Patienten fordern?
Ja gerne.
Es geht um Frau Helge Paulessen.
Ich kann nicht mehr russisch sagen.
Alles gut.
Okay.
Es geht um Frau Helge Paulessen.
Sie ist 65 Jahre alt, geboren am 26.11.1961.
Sie ist 1,56 m groß und wiegt 85 kg.
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen gestern Abend bestehender Bauchschmerzen im linken Unterbauch.
Laut Aufsage der Patientin sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen im mittleren Unterbauch ausgetragen sind.
Nach Angaben der Patientin sind die Schmerzen drückend, progredient und persistierend.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 von 10 auf der NRS.
Die Schmerzen verschlimmern sich beim Stuhlgang.
Außerdem erwähnt sie, dass sie mit 20. Lebensjahr eine ähnliche Beschwerde hatte.
Deswegen wurde bei ihr eine Appendiktomie durchgeführt.
Sie klagt mit Fieber bis 38,5°C.
Sie hat seit 3 Tagen Unüberhöhung.
Sie ist Polakin.
Sie hat auch seit 2 Tagen Obstipation.
Seit 2 Wochen?
Seit 2 Wochen Obstipation.
Alles klar.
Vegetative Anamnestis ergab sich in Appetenz- und Schmerzbedingte Dysomnie.
Sie ist seit 12 Jahren in einer Pause.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet sie seit 2 Jahren an arterieller Hypertonie.
An Operationen ist eine Appendiktomie bekannt.
Sie nimmt bei Bedarf Abführsmittel und regelmäßig 1x morgens 5 mg Ramibri ein.
Sie hat keine Allergie.
Die Noxen-Anamnese war unauffällig.
Die Familienanamnese ergab Diabetes Typ 2 beim Vater, Altersschwäche bei der Mutter.
Sozialanamnestisch ist sie ledig.
Momentan ist sie im Ruhestand.
Im Ruhestand hat sie früher als Sekretärin gearbeitet.
Sie hat keine Kinder.
Nach den amnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf...
Entschuldigung, was haben Sie über Ihren Vater?
Ich habe akustisch nicht gehört.
Diabetes Typ 2.
An der Komplikation des Diabetes ist er verstorben.
Keine Kolonkrebs?
Die Patientin hat das nicht erwähnt.
War die Operation komplikationslos?
Mit 25 Jahren.
Wann hat er die Appendiktum?
Die Frage wurde nicht gestellt.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Vielleicht hat er Narkose und Verträglichkeit.
Sie hat erwähnt, bei der Allergie-Anamnese.
Nach der Operation hatte sie Beschwerden.
Wahrscheinlich wegen der Narkose.
Sie hat das erwähnt.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Vielleicht werden wir Ihre Patientin auch Operation durchführen.
Das gibt wichtige Informationen.
Weiter machen Sie bitte.
Nach den amnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf Divertikulitis.
Wofür sprechen Sie?
Ich würde sagen, dass die Beschwerdebilde dafür sprechen.
Der Patient hat eine linke Schmerzen.
Eine drückende Schmerzen.
Eine Stuhlgangverschlechterung.
Sie hat auch Fieber.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es einen Zusammenhang zwischen Obstipation und diese Beschwerde.
Langzeitige Obstipation kann dazu führen.
Blutimpschtül.
Blutimpschtül kann sein.
Vielleicht auch mit Wasserlassen.
Wasserlassen kann ein getrenntes Beschwerdebild sein.
Auch ein Zusammenhang zwischen dieser Verdachtsdiagnose.
Ich werde das bei weiteren Untersuchungen erklären.
Machen Sie bitte.
Bei meiner Differenzialdiagnose kommen Kolonkarzinom und Handweginfektionen.
Gibt es eine S-Bildung zwischen Ihnen?
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde danach Blut für das Labor abnehmen und Urin- und Stuhluntersuchungen durchführen.
Außerdem sollte eine EKG geschrieben werden, um eine mögliche Herzursache auszuschließen.
Ich werde auch Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine CT-Adome verlassen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich diese Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde die Nahrungskarenz, die Flüssigkeit, die Elektrolytsubstitution und die symptomatische Analgetik und Antibiotik verordnen.
Natürlich ist es sehr wichtig, eine sofortige chirurgische Konzertsuche zu machen.
Ich empfehle, dass ich auch später eine reiche Ernährung und ausreichende Flüssigkeit konsumieren kann.
Ich würde auch eine reiche Ernährung und ausreichende Flüssigkeit konsumieren.
Ich empfehle, eine reiche Ernährung und ausreichende Flüssigkeit konsumieren.
Ich würde regelmäßig Sport machen oder sich bewegen.
Ich würde auch eine reiche Ernährung für die Keulenhydrate vermeiden.
Balasstoffreiche Ernährung empfehlen oder das wäre ein Risikofaktor für die Reiche Ernährung.
Nein, eine balasstoffarme Ernährung ist ein Risikofaktor dafür.
Umgekehrt wird es empfohlen, sich balasstoffreich zu ernähren.
Und auch die Observation zu vermeiden ist sehr wichtig.
Und unser Patient ist übergewicht, deswegen ist es auch wichtig, Gewicht zu reduzieren.
Und vielleicht später in akuter Divertikulitis vermeiden wir eine Koloskopie.
Aber vielleicht nach sechs Wochen würden wir oder veranlassen wir eine Koloskopie.
Ok, danke schön, Herr Doan.
Sie haben es gut gemacht.
Können wir jetzt, wenn Sie möchten, ein paar Erfahrungen lesen?
Was denken Sie?
Ja, ja.
Letzte Erfahrung habe ich.
Leider kann ich nicht in dieser Woche.
Ich vermute, dass ich neue Fälle bekomme.
Aber ich kann leider nicht gefunden.
Dann schauen wir.
Ist dieser Fall letzte Woche gekommen?
Ja, er ist gekommen.
Deswegen, das war in der Danish Group, aber ich kann leider nicht gefunden.
Neue Fälle, neue Erfahrungen.
Aber früher habe ich Erfahrungen.
Ich möchte diese Satze lesen für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Ist es wichtig oder falsch oder können wir nutzen, weiß ich nicht.
Die Prüflinke hat gesagt, dass ich nicht mehr in der Schule bin.
Aber die Patienten sagen, dass ich in der Schule bin.
Aber ich bin in der Schule.
Und ich werde in der Schule sein.
Die Prüflinke hat gesagt, dass sie nicht mehr in der Schule sein muss.
Wie werden wir das machen?
Die Prüflinke ist so, wie die Apandisit auf der linken Seite.
Darum sind es so.
Aber die Apandisit ist auf der rechten Seite.
Die beiden sind unter der Knie.
Eine auf der rechten Seite, eine auf der linken.
Deswegen sind es so.
Können wir den Obergartisten, der hier in die Prüflinke war,
die Prüflinke 5 geben?
Er hat gesagt, dass er 5 geben sollte.
Aber...
Nein, wenn der Patient das gesagt hat,
hat er das für die Apandisit gesagt.
Aber das ist das Klinik.
Er hat eine ähnliche Schmerz.
Ich glaube, das ist so, wie der Professor es vorgibt.
Okay, wir können es so ausprobieren.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Aber natürlich, das ist in der richtigen Unterbarung.
Ja, natürlich.
Am Ende man kann...
Aber es gibt auch eine Karnharris.
Aber es ist ein Saatold.
Er ist ein Apandisit.
Er kann auch in Meckar sein.
Aber er ist ein Karnharris.
Vielleicht ist er dann auch da.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Der Patient im Protokoll hat erwähnt,
oder erwähnt,
dass die Vater,
oder dass ihr Vater...
Ja, ich komme da.
an Kolonkarsinom gelitten.
Aber heutige Patientin hat das nicht erwähnt.
Deswegen würde ich gerne wissen,
ob ich auch differenzial diagnostisch
Kolonkarsinom ausdenken kann.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
ob ich auch in meinem Papier
keine Dampfkrebskarsinom habe.
Ich glaube.
Okay.
Wenn ich hier bin,
habe ich keine Dampfkrebskarsinom.
Beni,
können wir bitten um sie...
Entschuldigung.
Können wir bitten um sie?
Vielleicht können sie auch Sumeras-Dokumente
oder andere Fälle,
auch wie Protokoll meine ich,
können...
Entschuldigung.
Die Vertikulierung ist nicht auch...
Nur eine Dokument haben wir.
Die Vertikulierung ist anders ein bisschen.
Aber wir können auch sie schicken.
Ich denke...
Entschuldigung.
Darf ich...
Ja.
Bis jetzt...
Vielleicht ist das auch für sie ganz wichtig.
Beni, Herr Beni...
Um wichtige Beschwerden
oder Informationen zu finden.
Deswegen vielleicht können sie auch vergleichen.
Sumeras ist bei uns
letzte Purifier-Link.
Herr Chetin.
Nicht letzte, aber
Ibrahim und...
Leider Ibrahim hat auch keine Dokumente
über die Vertikulose.
Aber wir können ihn gruppen schauen.
Ich denke...
Ich denke die Vertikulose
ist in der Purifik.
Sie ist einfach.
Nein, sie ist nicht.
Sie ist nicht.
Ich kann nicht.
Andere Informationen,
die ich noch nicht verstanden habe,
sind nicht in der Purifik.
Ich denke...
Es ist nicht wichtig,
weil die Patienten
diese Schmerzen
und die Blut im Blut haben.
Ich denke,
es ist entweder
die Vertikulose
oder
dann die Krebskarsen.
Natürlich denke ich,
es ist nicht verständlich.
Aber meine Papiere habe keine Informationen.
Außerdem...
Aber alles gut.
Das ist für Sie auch ganz wichtig.
Ja.
Außerdem...
Ich möchte sagen,
als differential Diagnose
mein Doğan hat gefragt,
ich meine über diese Falle
Karsen und
Üstereitifkulitis.
Nein, keine Hanfwege-Infektion.
Ja, okay.
Keine Hanfwege-Infektion
befindet sich in der Falle.
Okay.
Jetzt kommen wir zu dem ersten Punkt.
Ich möchte Sie kurz beantworten.
Ja.
Ich habe gerade
eine Analyse gemacht.
Ich habe gesagt,
Krebs,
also Karsen und
Üstereitifkulitis.
Ja, gerade
habe ich gerade gesagt,
Hanfwege-Infektion.
Natürlich.
Aber Üstereitifkulitis
ist eine besondere Krankheit.
Wenn du die Prüfung
in der Prüfung gut erklärt hast,
Üstereitifkulitis,
ist es sehr gut.
Kein Problem.
Ich wollte sagen,
aber weil der Patient
65 Jahre alt ist,
habe ich das ausgeschlossen.
Deswegen habe ich nichts geschrieben.
Die Alter,
das ist zum ersten Mal.
Und ähnliche Beschwerden
sind zum ersten Mal.
Und keine Wiederholung
oder Wiederkehrenverhalten.
Und der Patient
ist 65 Jahre alt.
Üstereitifkulitis erwarten wir vielleicht
früher.
Ja, vielleicht 40 Jahre.
Kann sein, aber deswegen habe ich das
ausgeschlossen.
Richtig, aber selten.
Aber ist es nicht möglich.
Ach so, ja, natürlich.
Heute Morgen habe ich für Sie
eine Erfahrung gelesen.
Prüfung hat gesagt,
Üstereitifkulitis und
Karsinom,
Prüfer ist sehr gut.
Okay, ich schreibe.
Vielleicht.
Statt Hansinfekt
kann ich Üstereitifkulitis schreiben.
Weil ich ein bisschen besser
den Vergleich zu anders
besser erklären kann.
Ich möchte etwas sagen.
Früher habe ich
gesagt,
Herr Dogan,
Ich glaube,
können wir
keine Darmentsündung,
Dichtarmentsündung
sagen.
Dichtarm oder Darmentsündung sagen?
Ich kann mich nicht
daran erinnern.
Dichtarm oder?
Dichtarm.
Darf ich fragen,
für Dr. Benny,
warum gibt es
bei Dichtarm
ein Problem?
Ja, richtig.
Ich glaube,
es ist ein Problem,
aber ich denke,
bei dem Patienten
kann ich es nicht machen.
Aber bei dieser Situation
hat der Patienten
ein bisschen mehr
zu tun.
Er kann es nicht
machen,
aber
ich denke,
es ist ein problem.
Darf ich fragen,
ob es ein Problem ist?
Ist es ein Problem?
Darf ich
fragen,
ob es ein Problem ist?
die Dürrken beschwerden.
Beim Dürrken sagen sie Füstchen,
die Füste und so weiter.
So ist es, denken wir, so ist es.
Aber besonders bei den Patienten
können wir sagen in der Prüfung,
so ist es, denken wir,
Handwerkenfüste und dann
kondensierte Füstchen.
Also Kommunikationen kann kompliziert sein.
Aber dabei kann ich denken,
dass die Urin-Muss-Trübe
oder die Fekaliten...
Richtig, richtig.
Was ist das Problem?
Ist andere Krankheit
oder denken sie?
Ja.
Okay, danke.
Herr Ibrahim, bitte.
Danke schön.
Als Differential Diagnose
würden wir zum Beispiel
Urolithiasis oder Colitis-Ürsache haben.
Aber kann man so denken,
zum Beispiel Amoebische Colitis
ist gleich zu oder ähnlich beschwerden?
Ja, Amoebische Colitis
oder Noa Colitis.
Noa Colitis, ja, okay.
Aber das ist ein spezifischer Diagnos.
Die Prüfung,
hochwahrscheinlich, möchten wir von uns
oder das ist richtig, ist es.
Das ist Karsino und
Ustratikolid
durch diese
Handwerk-Infektion.
Handwerk-Infektion oder
Colitis-Ürseroza.
Sie würden diese
Differential Diagnose schreiben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Karsino und
Handwerk-Infektion.
Ich wollte Karsino und
Ustratikolid
und Prüfung
und das ist mir nicht egal.
Nein, diese letzte Erfahrung,
Herr Benih,
diese Prüferin hat
Ustratikolid und
Karsino geschrieben.
Ja, ja.
Der Oberarzt hat
zufrieden.
Aber heute,
unser Pärchen, Herr Doğan,
heute unsere Patienten
haben Ungewichtswertveränderung.
Nein, aber ich meine,
die Verstopfung ist überwiegend.
Ustratikolid erwarten wir
zu häufig.
Oder?
Ja, häufig
ist es Schutulkrank und
Blut, Sufir.
Anbieten
verständlich
ein bisschen.
Aber denken wir an die Örgünheit.
Ok.
Entschuldigung.
Gestern Abend hat Frau Danis
ein bisschen
anders
Informationen gegeben.
Zum Beispiel
FSP hat nicht nur
Fachsprachprüfung,
sondern auch Kätnisse.
Haben Sie das gehört?
Ja, ja, leider.
Ich möchte nicht nochmal hören.
Und sie hat gesagt,
dass wir
ausführliche Informationen
bezüglich Fälle
lernen müssen.
Und natürlich werden wir
diese Fälle
ausführlich diskutieren
und ausführliche Informationen
erhalten.
Und natürlich werden wir
die Vertikulose,
die Vertikulitis,
die häufigsten Ursachen
und häufigsten Symptome
und die Versorgung,
die wir in der Zeit haben.
Diese Fälle sind nicht schwer,
aber wenn Kätnisse
oder Informationen
beurteilt werden,
dann ist das nicht einfach.
Ja?
Ok, ja.
Herr Doğan,
hat unsere Patientin Fieber?
Ja, Fieber war 38,8 Grad.
Ok. Wo hat sie gemessen?
Da habe ich es nicht gemessen.
Ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Dann wurde ich nicht gestellt.
Leider.
Aber ich werde
bei der Körperliche Antersuchung
natürlich wieder als Vitalparameter
den Körpertemperatur kontrollieren.
Deswegen mache ich das.
Ok, danke.
Wo kauft diese Frau
Abführsmittel?
Weil es nicht wichtig ist, habe ich nicht.
Ich meine, Entschuldigung,
ist das ärztliche Rat oder?
Natürlich.
Ich werde das
bei der Körperliche Antersuchung abklären.
Gerne.
Hat sie zwei Wochen
Stuhlgang?
Verstopfung.
Sie hat seit zwei Wochen
Hat sie deswegen
einen Arzt besucht?
Oder möchte ich das fragen?
Wissen.
Beschwerden oder
wegen diesem Beschwerdenkomplex.
Nicht nur wegen
Obstipation habe ich gefragt.
Aber der Patient hat erzählt,
die damalige Operation
wegen diesem Beschwerden
nicht nur Schmerzen.
Aber bezüglich
Schmerzen hat der Patient
vermutlich verstanden.
Deswegen hat sie so
beantwortet.
Haben Sie ihre
Gewohnheiten gefragt?
Über Ernährung?
Nein.
Ich frage sie nur,
ich wünsche ihnen Entschuldigung.
Sie haben es auch.
Ich weiß nicht,
aber ich denke,
das ist eine Verrückung.
Sie haben es auch.
Ich habe es auch.
Aber bezüglich
Schmerzen kann es nicht sein.
Wir haben diese Schmerzen
mit
Familienbelastung
und
Vater hat Polyp
oder Vater hat Kolonkarsen.
Oder Mutter, weiß ich nicht.
Aber immer Familienbelastung
auch Polyp.
Und?
Ich lese.
Aber ich muss auch wählen,
welche ist wichtig oder so.
Welche Gruppe gehört
Ramiplit?
Ramiplit ist eine
AC HEMA.
Oder wie kann man das aussprechen?
Angiotensin-Konverter
in HEMA.
Was ist die Vertikulitis?
Eine Entzündung
in der Darm. Und?
Entzündete
in der Darm.
Aus Stülpunk?
Was bedeutet
aus Stülpunk?
Wegen
langsamer
Obzipation kann das
austreten.
Die alle
Darmwandstiche
oder Stiche
können ballonartig
draußen verlegen.
Schleimhaut
des Darm
oder?
Nicht Schleimhaut.
Auch die
tiefere Stiche.
Oder habe ich falsch erklärt?
Nicht Schleimhaut.
Beni, können Sie uns helfen?
Ich habe eine Gitarre.
Okay.
Was ist die Divertikulose?
Kann ich das?
Die Divertikulose
bezeichnet das
Vorhandensein von Divertikeln
ohne Entzündung.
Bei der Divertikulose
liegen multiple Divertikel
im Kolon vor.
Meist im Sigma.
Keine Entzündungszeichen.
Im Gegensatz zu
Divertikulitis.
Divertikel
ist
aus Schüppeltung der Darmwand.
Ohne einen Divertikel.
Aber mehrere Divertikel
ist Divertikulose.
Und wenn
Divertikel
entzündet sich,
Divertikulitis.
Welche Wandschichte
ist das? Schleimhaut?
Oder nicht Schleimhaut?
Mukoza und
Suppmukoza.
Was ist aus Schüppeltung?
Aus Schüppeltung ist ein
Aus Schüppeltung ist
ein
in Deutsch bitte.
Deutsch bitte.
Ein Milizien.
Aus Schüppeltung ist
ein
Vorwürfung.
Ja. Vorwürfung.
Ich kann
auch
vorlesen.
Aus Schüppeltung ist ein
ein sachartiges Vorwürfung.
Oder hervorgetreten von
Gewebe nach außen.
Das ist sehr gute Information.
Können Sie uns diese Satze schicken bitte?
Eine Schüppeltung ist eine
sachartige Vorwürfung.
Können Sie uns diese
Satze schicken bitte?
Gleich.
Okay.
Kann ich etwas fragen?
Wenn es nicht schüttelt, kann man es
mit herniatischen sagen?
Nein, nein, wir können es nicht sagen.
Mukoza und Suppmukoza
schütteln aus Schüppeltung
nach außen.
Schütteln.
Gut, danke schön.
Aus Schütteltung ist eine
sachartige Vorwürfung.
Oder hervorgetreten von
Gewebe nach außen.
Mukoza und Suppmukoza.
Ich habe hier
ein paar Töne.
Ich habe hier ein paar Töne.
Okay.
Herr Chetin, Herr Doğan,
was ist das CT
Nachteil?
Zuerst?
Meinen Sie ein
Bildgebendepfaren?
Okay.
Die Strahlenmenge.
Und auch
wenn wir
ein CT
mit Kontrastmittel
verlassen,
werden wir den Patienten natürlich
kontrastmittel.
Kontrastmittel kann
nierenschädlich sein.
Es ist auch eine Nachteil.
Und auch die klostrophobische
Menschen kann das
unangenehm sein.
Ich meine wichtigster
die Antwort ist
wichtigster Nachteil, das ist
Strahlenbelastung.
Aber auch Kontrastmittel kann sein.
Okay.
Da bin ich nicht sicher, aber
mit der Patienten hat
Kolostrophobie
in Dortmund...
Platzangst.
Vielleicht in Dortmund
gibt es offene
CT oder MRT?
Es gibt auch in der Türkei
viele offene CT für
klostrophobische
Patienten.
Aber okay. Dann
wichtigster Nachteil ist
Strahlenbelastung. Und in
welcher Einheit wird die
Strahlenbelastung
gemessen? Wissen Sie?
Einheit ist
Radiationschwäch.
Strahlenbelastung.
Dann Pürfeling
hat diese Frage
als dies antwortet.
Ich könnte sicherlich
nicht alle Fragen beantworten,
hat gesagt.
Dann die Oberarztin Leherlich
über ihn.
Das ist eine
Radiationbremse.
Okay. Lernen Sie bitte.
Dann schreiben Sie uns bitte.
Okay. Dann
lese ich anders.
Was ist Mumps?
Das ist Ziegenpeter.
Ziegenpeter. Auf Deutsch
Ziegenpeter.
Okay. Weiß ich nicht.
Peter.
Ziegenpeter. Okay.
Ein Fachbegriff.
Paratoides.
Ja. Ich meine das.
Paratoid Drüsenentzündung.
Paratitis.
Drüsenentzündung.
Welche Komplikationen
gibt es?
Gehe.
Bustabeln Sie bitte.
Gehe wie Gustav.
Und kleine Yoga.
Nein.
Okay. Was heißt das?
Die Einheit der
Radiation oder
Strahlen.
Die Komplikationen
der Mumps
wichtigste ist Unfruchtbarkeit
wegen wahrscheinlich
Orchiditis.
Und auch Meningitis.
Encephalitis kann sein.
Und Orchid.
Und Paratitis.
Zwei wichtigste
Zwei wichtigste Zwei
Encephalitis und Orchitis.
Okay.
Vielleicht Meningitis.
Kann sein.
Unterschied zwischen Parese und
Parästhesie.
Eine ist Lehmung. Andere
Sensibilitätsstörungen.
Nein. Die beiden sind nicht Lehmungen.
Nein. Eine.
Parästhesie ist
Sensibilitätsstörungen.
Heißt auf Deutsch
Kribeln.
Und Parasite ist Lehmung.
Okay.
Hab ich schon falsch gesagt?
Was ist Taubheitsgefühl?
Taubheitsgefühl ist
Hypoästhesie.
Hypoästhesie oder
Hypostese. Ich weiß nicht
die richtige Schreibung.
Ich weiß auch nicht. Aber
Kribeln ist
Parasite. Sie haben recht.
Wie Ameislaufen.
Und Hypokalemia.
Und komme ich zurück.
Ja.
Immer
Differentialdiagnose
Colitis ulcerosa und
Koloncarcinome geschrieben. Die anderen
prüferen auch.
Die Kommission
mögen diese Differentialdiagnosen
für diese Fälle.
Und ja.
Gleiche Fragen.
Was ist ein Möckelvertikel?
Haben Sie erklärt oder?
Angeborene
aus Stülpunk.
Aber nicht
nur Mukosal und
Submukosal Schichten.
Sondern auch
die Gewebe- und Glatmuskelschlache
Schicht.
Glatmuskelschlach
Schicht und die Gewebe.
Und Bindgewebe.
Echt?
Ja.
Die Differentialdiagnosen
sind meistens
wegen der Pseudo-Differentialdiagnose
bei der Pseudo-Differentialdiagnose
gibt es nur zwei
Schichten.
Die Verlegerung
der zwei Schichten.
Mukoza und Submukoza. Aber bei Möckel
alle Wandschichten
aus Müskulärer
Style.
Alle Wandschichten
heißen Mukoza,
Submukoza, Glatmuskel
Stiche und
Bindgewebe. Und auch die
Darmfälle.
Darf ich
vorlesen?
Das Möckelvertikel
ist eine angeborene
Ausstülpung des Dünndarms.
Meist in
Illium und Echtvertikel.
Ich möchte auch wissen
ob
die Schichten
in Illium sind.
Manchmal
mit diesem Patienten
möchte ich fragen,
ob
eine Apendektomie
durchgeführt wird.
Das heißt, keine
Möckelvertikel sein.
Bei der Apendektomie
auch
Möckelvertikel
entfernen.
Das ist die gleiche Stelle.
Aber vielleicht
habe ich es nicht.
Meistens
Möckelvertikel
sind
recht.
Weil ein Teil
Dünndarms
in Illium ist.
Was heißt
Illium in Deutsch?
Crum darm oder
Löffinger darm
oder Entler darm oder
Crum darm.
Schauen Sie uns das mal an.
Crum darm, denke ich.
Illium in Deutsch.
Nicht Illium,
Illium.
Können Sie es bitte wiederholen?
Was ist
Illium in Deutsch?
Was ist?
Crum darm.
Lärrdarm, Crum darm.
Okay.
Duetunum derdarm.
Jehenun derlierdarm.
Illium dercrumdarm.
Ich kenne sie.
Okay.
Herketin, ich habe eine Frage.
Aber heute möchte ich
noch mal wiederholen.
Wo kann man
im Augensehen
sehen?
Das heißt?
Verfärbt gelblich.
Oder
verfärbt gelblich.
Okay. Leatherhaut in Fachbegriff?
Siklera.
Okay, danke.
Okay, Leatherhaut.
Okay.
Muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Hat der die Patienten gefragt?
Muss sie im Krankenhaus?
Er hat gefragt.
Was haben Sie geantwortet?
Abla, ich möchte das nicht wiederholen.
Dann, das ist etwas Kürtiges.
Okay. In diesem Fall
hat die Patientin
auch manchmal Laktosunverträglichkeit.
Reagiert auch Bauchschmerzen.
Und Blöcken.
Das ist durchaus ja.
Bei mir alles
Nuss.
Movikol Tabletten.
Wissen Sie, was ist das?
Vielleicht kann das eine
gegen Reissam-Syndrom sein?
Oder gegen
Obstpastien.
Was ist das?
Können Sie bitte schauen?
Oder Movikol Tabletten.
Movikol Tabletten.
Drei Mal Provochen.
Ich denke, das ist für
Verstopfen.
Ich schaue.
Das ist ein Medikament.
Oder für Mit-Telo-Das-O.
Das ist Tabletten.
Das ist Wirkstoff.
Wirkstoff.
Oder Generik.
Was ist das?
Polyethylen Glykol.
Okay.
Bursakta su tutarak.
Das ist ein Medikament.
Okay.
Was denken Sie über
Operationen per Chatin?
Wenn die Vertikulierung
nicht komplizierter
komplizierter ist,
warten wir nur
sechs Wochen zu
Koloskopie ab.
Ja, vielleicht wenn
komplizierter mit
Perforationen
oder Fistülen oder Absenzen
je nach Ursache,
je nach Komplikation
operieren wir.
Wenn eine Absenzen
sollten wir
die Absenzen dringend
abflüssen.
Oder ausflüssen.
Ausflüssen.
Ja, wenn es
ein Fistül gibt,
sollten wir Fistülreparature
durchführen.
Ja.
Oder Perforation
eine Rezension.
Partielle Rezension
kann auch vertailliert sein.
Ja.
Rezension des Betrophenen
darmabschinitz.
Ja, Partielle, ja, Betrophene.
Betrophene darmabschinitz.
Okay.
Folnarkose unfertileglischkeit
die de geçmiş, hoja.
Bauchimertzin und Bileyung die
vollnarkose unfertileglischkeit
die
Kann man eine Unverträglichkeit schreiben?
Ich würde so schreiben, zum Beispiel als Gulli Latour mit dem Toleranz.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es richtig ist oder nicht.